einen schönen guten abend herr low
zusammen wir gehen live mit zdf heute
live die ema das ist die europäische
arzneimittelbehörde hat heute grünes
licht für die zulassung des baxter
impfstoffes für kinder von fünf bis elf
jahren gegeben das heißt voraussichtlich
bis ende des jahres wird es diesen
impfstoff in dieser altersgruppe auch in
deutschland geben das bedeutet dass das
warten für viele eltern die ihre kinder
gerne impfen lassen wollen ein ende hat
zumindest bald es gibt aber auch eltern
die sind dagegen ihre kinder impfen zu
lassen und es gibt viele eltern gehe
einfach noch unsicher sind
wenn das eigene kind betrifft und es
noch nicht wirklich erprobt und getestet
wurde wir müssen das im familienrat
nochmal beschließen wenn der impfstoff
da ist und wahrscheinlich lassen wir es
machen bestimmt ich als erster werden
unser kind unsere ältere tochter auf
jeden fall
impfen lassen sobald es geht ich wollte
diese stiko meldung abwarten weil ich
denke wenn man schon so eine kommission
hat dann möchte ich die auch
nehmen und wissen was die was sie davon
denken
also die meinungen gehen da durchaus
durch durchaus durcheinander und auch
auseinander und jeder der kinder hat
weiß dass er entweder freundes und
bekanntenkreis schon diverse
diskussionen geführt hat vor allem aber
ist die verunsicherung groß und da war
wurde am versuchen so viel wie möglich
zu erklären und aufzuklären und dabei
hilft uns professor deutsch er ist
direktor der kinderklinik der uni klinik
köln und er ist präsident der
gesellschaft für kinder und
jugendmedizin einen schönen guten abend
endet
genau wie jetzt ist es so dass natürlich
unsere userinnen und user gerne ihre
fragen schicken können und ihre
kommentare posten können und wir werden
dann versuchen so viel wie möglich davon
zu klären aber was würden sie sagen
jetzt gleich mal zu anfangen kinder
gegen korona impfen ja
nein vielleicht ja
es ist zunächst mal eine gute nachricht
das ist den impfstoff gibt denn ein
zugelassener impfstoff bedeutet
natürlich dass eine chancengleichheit
für die kinder auch besteht und dass sie
eine rechtlich sichere situation haben
wenn man sie in dieser rechtlich sichere
situation ist dann für die eltern und
auch für die erste gegeben also insofern
ist das erst mal sehr gut ob jetzt
dieser impfstoff in jedem fall einen
eigenen nutzen also einen individuellen
nutzen für das einzelne kind hat das
gilt es noch zu prüfen und dazu haben
wir die ständige impfkommission eine
expertenkommission die die dinge
bewertet und dann noch zu einer
empfehlung kommen wird darauf haben wir
auch gleich noch mal eingehen bevor wir
aber weiter sprechen laura wo sinus und
christoph giesel haben die wichtigsten
infos zu dieser entscheidung
zusammengefasst
die korona impfung für kinder ab fünf
jahren so wie hier in den usa bald wird
das auch in deutschland möglich sein der
impfstoff von beyond eck und pfizer ist
in europa der erste der für kinder im
grundschulalter
zugelassen sind am donnerstag hat die
europäische arzneimittelbehörde ema die
zulassung des impfstoffs empfohlen für
kinder im alter von fünf bis elf jahren
offiziell muss die eu kommission noch
zustimmen
das gilt allerdings als formsache
das vakzin für die fünf- bis elfjährigen
ist dabei nicht ganz identisch mit den
erwachsenen impfstoff
kindern wird nur ein drittel der
normalen dosis gespritzt nämlich zwei
impfdosen zu je zehn mikrogramm im
abstand von mindestens drei wochen
bei jugendlichen und erwachsenen sind
das je 30 mikrogramm trotz dieser
geringeren dosierung ist der kinder
impfstoff laut angaben der hersteller
wirksam und sicher in der
zulassungsstudie mit rund 2200 kinder
errechneten forscher innen eine
wirksamkeit von 90,7 prozent
schwere in verdingte nebenwirkungen
wurden dagegen nicht beobachtet
stattdessen gab es ausschließlich milde
und vorübergehende reaktionen wie fieber
schmerzen einstich müdigkeit oder
kopfschmerzen
allerdings sehr seltene nebenwirkungen
lassen sich in einer so vergleichsweise
kleinen gruppe kaum feststellen darauf
haben zuletzt auch immer wieder
mitglieder der stiko hingewiesen die
nach der zulassung der eu nun über eine
impfempfehlung für die fünf- bis
elfjährigen berät
wann die stiko ihre entscheidung
vorliegt ist offen sie sei eine
empfehlung bis ende dezember
experten erwarten dass zunächst seine
empfehlung für kinder mit
vorerkrankungen und schwer kranken
angehörigen kommen könnte
singt auf die stiko warten müssen kinder
eltern ärzten und ärzte aber nicht laut
gesundheitsministerium sollen die
impfung mit dem kinder impfstoff wie bei
allen anderen zugelassenen impfstoffen
schon vorher möglich sein nach
individueller entscheidung und
besprechung mit arzt oder ärztin
herr professor dich jetzt haben wir ja
gerade wahnsinns instanzen bei kinder
und jugendlichen vielleicht können wir
das einmal kurz zeigen wir haben hier
eine grafik auf seite erfreute de da
sind die instanzen nach alter in
deutschland sortiert vielleicht fangen
wir mal an zum vergleich kann man das
ganz gut sehen mit den über 85-jährigen
die sieht man hier und da sieht man hier
dass die bei
190 liegt und jetzt gehen wir mal auf
die null bis 14 jährigen da sind wir bei
500 und das sind zahlen aus dem
wochenbericht des rk ii dh der wird
immer donnerstags im laufe des tages
veröffentlicht und war jetzt diese woche
noch nicht darf für die vergangene woche
also es sind zahlen von letzter woche
man kann sich vorstellen wie sich diese
zahlen jetzt noch mal verändert haben
jetzt muss man auf der anderen seite ja
auch sagen dass kinder und jugendliche
glücklicherweise muss man sagen auch
nicht so oft schwer erkranken also
können sie nachvollziehen dass eltern
die entscheidung für eine impfung am
durchaus auch schwer fällt
absolut man muss hier als elternteil
immer überlegen was macht man wie macht
man die dinge richtig und wie macht man
alles richtig für seine kinder und das
ist immer eine abwägung zwischen der
infektion und der impfung und wir sehen
jetzt auf der einen seite sie haben das
sehr schön gezeigt dass natürlich die
über 80-jährigen oder über 85-jährigen
relativ niedrige instanzen haben das ist
natürlich auch dem impfstoff und da
jetzt auch einsetzen booster impfung zu
verdanken das ist ein riesenvorteil
und wichtig wäre jetzt natürlich in der
tat wie es auch in dem beitrag sehr
schön dargestellt ist ob für die kinder
ein solcher vorteil auch zu erreichen
ist man muss da unbedingt sagen ist es
der individuelle vorteil der bei den
kindern zelt und nicht der vorteil für
die gesellschaft also wir dürfen die
kinder nicht impfen um einen vorteil im
hinblick auf einer herdenimmunität oder
eine eindämmung des virus insgesamt zu
erreichen sondern es muss ganz klar sein
dass die kinder persönlich einen vorteil
davon haben
will geht auf youtube zehn schritte
weiter so sage ich mal er sagt corinna
ist faktisch für kinder und jugendliche
relativ ungefährlich sie dagegen zu
impfen ist ein verbrechen sagte die
nebenwirkungen sind weitaus schlimmer
als die erkrankung was würden sie darauf
antworten
ja ich glaube dafür ist es wichtig dass
wir unsere ständige impfkommission haben
denn die prüft natürlich genau die frage
ob die nebenwirkung gravierender sind
als die wirkung der infektion die
ständige impfkommission wird nur dann
den impfstoff empfehlen wenn die
nebenwirkung deutlich geringer sind als
komplikationen die die krankheit selbst
verursacht und das ist eben die gute
nachricht für die eltern dass diese
kommission die aufseher langjährigen
experten besteht aus vielen experten aus
verschiedenen bereichen
dass diese kommission die auch ständig
tag ständig alle neuen ergebnisse sich
anschaut sich die entscheidung nicht
leicht macht und vor allem das ist auch
ganz wichtig das wissen wir aus den
vorangegangenen entscheidungen sie
entscheidet nicht auf basis des drucks
den die politik ausübt sondern nehme sie
entscheidet lediglich aufgrund
wissenschaftlicher daten also ihres
wissens und ihres gewissens
sie haben jetzt die ständige
impfkommission
angesprochen dann bleiben wir auch
direkt dabei es ist jetzt so dass die
immer grünes licht für die zulassung
dieses impfstoffs gegeben hat dann kommt
jetzt das paul ehrlich institut für
deutschland wann und wird den impfstoff
für deutschlands zu lassen und dann wird
sich die ständige impfkommission dazu
äußern mit einer empfehlung einer
eingeschränkten empfehlung oder eben
auch nicht das wissen wir nicht das will
sie bis kurz vor weihnachten machen
vielen dauert das jetzt auch gerade in
der aktuellen situation viel zu lange
noch und deshalb haben wir martin
terhardt kinder- und jugendmediziner und
eben mitglied der ständigen
impfkommission gefragt um das denn so
lange dauert
also sehen sind in der stiko in der
arbeitsgruppe der kinder impfung dabei
dieses thema zu beraten und die
wissenschaftliche evidenz für eine
empfehlung auszuarbeiten und zu dieser
beratung gehört natürlich das wäldchen
sämtlicher daten die du zu diesem thema
zur verfügung stehen das sind die daten
aus der zulassungsstudie die jetzt in
allen ländern verwendet werden weil es
sich über ein und denselben impfstoff
und dieselbe zulassungsstudie handelt
wir müssen aber auch die daten aus
deutschland was die krankheitslast
dieser altersgruppe angeht und das
risiko
der gesunden bevölkerung dieser
altersklasse und das risiko zu erkranken
in denen bei den kindern mit chronischen
erkrankungen das müssen wir jetzt genau
bewerten um das ins verhältnis zu setzen
zum eventuellen risiko das durch die
impfung verbunden sein könnte und da
fehlen uns in der tat noch etwas daten
und die erwarten wir gerade aus den usa
wo er jetzt in hohem tempo diese impfung
seit zweieinhalb wochen durchgeführt
wird und wir warten dann auf daten aus
der überwachung was einen eventuellen
komplikationen vielleicht auftritt was
wir nicht hoffen was wir aber ja bei den
jugendlichen über den jugend erwachsenen
durchaus erlebt haben mit den herzmuskel
entzündung und ob wir diese daten bis
zum 20 dezember bekommen das kann ich
nicht versprechen aber das ist das datum
wann wir fertig sein wollen spätestens
weil dann auch der impfstoff in
deutschland zur verfügung stehen wird
wird viel fragt auf youtube wie sicher
ist die impfung welche nebenwirkungen
sind bislang bekannt vielleicht können
sie das noch mal aufzählen
ja es geht ja um den impfstoff muss man
entscheidet unterscheidet natürlich
zwischen akuten reaktionen also da
gehört dazu dass das natürlich
schmerzhaft ist zunächst mal die
injektion auch danach noch schmerzhaft
sein kann dass man
symptome haben kann die an einer
erkältung erinnern inklusive
schüttelfrost das sind sozusagen
allgemeine nebenwirkungen einer impfung
in den ersten tagen
wenige tage nach der impfung kann es wie
eben dem beitrag auch gehört
insbesondere bei männlichen jugendlichen
zu einer leichten herzmuskelentzündung
kommen das betrifft nach allem was wir
bis jetzt wissen in etwa jeden 16.000
jugendlichen und es ist bis jetzt haben
wir zum glück keine schweren verläufe
gesehen es ist also damit eine
vorübergehende komplikation und wir
gehen davon aus dass bei allen
jugendlichen und kindern die eine solche
herzmuskelentzündung
auch eine vollständige ausheilung
zur folge sein wird ganz wichtiges eben
auch zu sagen dass dieser impfstoff sehr
schnell im körper abgebaut wird er kann
nicht in die dna also das erbgut der
zellen eingebaut werden das ist ja eine
sorge die viele hatten in der
anfangsphase aber das kann man wieder
legen und insofern sind keine
langfristigen nebenwirkungen der impfung
zu erwarten
jetzt ist es ja so dass wir in dieser
pandemie gelernt haben dass kinder und
jugendliche vor allem psychisch
wahnsinnig unter dieser situation
gelitten haben unter den kontakt
beschränkungen unter den schul und kita
schließungen
dann mal abgesehen von dieser
organischen frage wie schwer die
krankheitsverläufe sind ist das
vielleicht auch ein argument für eine
impfung von kindern dass sie einfach
wieder die möglichkeit haben am
gesellschaftlichen leben mehr
teilzunehmen
ja das ist ganz richtig also wie sie
richtig sagen einerseits sind die
krankheitsverläufe in der regel nicht
schwer aber es gibt doch schwere
verläufe davor kann eine impfung die
kinder schützen und es schützt natürlich
die kinder auch davor dass sie schule
verpassen oder die teilhabe am sozialen
leben dadurch dass sie sich eben
aufgrund einer infektion isolieren
müssen und wir wissen sehr genau dass
diese phasen der isolation während des
lockouts unglaublich viele
schwierigkeiten bei vielen kindern und
jugendlichen angerichtet haben
seelischer natur aber auch körperlicher
natur
sie haben sehr viel mit kindern zu tun
und job bedingt sie haben natürlich
dadurch auch sehr viel mit eltern zu tun
hier schreibt jetzt thomas kirschbaum
auf youtube unsere kinder werden nicht
geimpft das bestimmen wir und wir
bleiben auch um geimpft
erwarten sie dass das auch so eine
heftige diskussion werden wird wie es im
moment unter den ungeimpften erwachsenen
und dem geimpften diese diese spaltung
erwarten sie die auch dass es da heftige
diskussionen geben wird
das glaube ich nicht die erwachsenen
haben in der tat zwei aspekte zu
betrachten im hinblick auf die impfung
einmal natürlich den schutz den eigenen
schutz und zweitens aber die
verantwortung die sie als teil der
gesellschaft haben nämlich andere
menschen zu schützen insbesondere sie
haben sich am anfang auch erklärt die
älteren menschen die ich trotz impfung
die infektion ja manchmal bekommen
können und die wollen wir unbedingt
schützen gehen wollen wir ersparen dass
sie eben an der krone erkrankung schwer
kranken oder gar sterben diesen auftrag
haben wir als erwachsene
bei kindern ist das anders da gibt es
diesen auftrag nicht für kinder gilt es
alleine den eigenen schutz zu
gewährleisten und insofern ist es kein
spalten des moment für die gesellschaft
sondern hier wird es darum gehen können
wir zeigen dass der impfstoff den
kindern mehr vorteile oder mehr
nachteile bringt uns danach können dann
die eltern mit der entsprechenden
informationen die ihnen dann vorliegt
wirklich guten gewissens entscheiden
haben sie denn persönlich verständnis
dafür wenn erwachsene sich nicht impfen
lassen denn damit schützen sie ja
eigentlich auch die kinder
ja das ist eine eine sehr schwierige
diskussion im moment wir erwachsene
haben die pflicht für andere mit zu
denken das ist teil unseres auftrags das
ist teil unserer gesellschaftlichen
situation darauf haben wir uns rein
gelassen und es ist es gibt momente da
müssen wir als erwachsene letztlich
dinge in kauf nehmen die dazu dienen dem
rest der gesellschaft auch ein leben in
freiheit ein leben in gesundheit zu
ermöglichen und deswegen ist es so
wichtig dass wir erwachsene uns alle
impfen und unsere eigenen interessen
dann manchmal auch ein kleines stück in
den hintergrund setzen damit die gesamte
gesellschaft damit alle unsere
mitmenschen auch letztlich geschützt und
teilweise gerettet werden können denn
wir auch von uns natürlich als
erwachsene auch für unsere kinder und
für uns selbst dass die anderen das auch
tun der straßenverkehr ist ein beispiel
wo das auch nötig ist und wo wir das
auch tun und
deswegen ist das auch so wichtig im
hinblick auf die impfung das ist eine
ganz vergleichbare situation
und man muss auch ehrlicherweise sagen
das virus selbst macht ja nichts anderes
als das ist eine zelle
das bringt genauso wie die impfung in
eine zelle eines formiert sich nur noch
viel öfter aber es passiert im prinzip
das gleiche wie mit der impfung und
insofern ist es aus medizinischer sicht
kein prinzipieller unterschied ob man
sich impft oder ob ein virus sozusagen
diese impfung selbst übernimmt das ist
kein prinzipieller unterschied aber es
ist sehr wohl einen unterschied in der
ausprägung die impfung selbst macht eben
nur eine geringe immunreaktion sie ist
sehr spezifisch das virus selbst
vermehrt sich permanent kann eine
unkontrollierte ausbreitung machen und
das führt natürlich auch dazu dass viel
viel mehr proteine freigesetzt werden
auf die eine viel stärkere immunreaktion
kommt und das kann viel leichter dann
zum beispiel auch spätere leben und
reaktionen auslösen wir wissen dass
beispielsweise bei den kindern
anhand des so genannten pimm's zentrums
genau eine infektion bei kindern und
jugendlichen heißt erstmal kann erstmal
alles heißen dass die symptome verläuft
oder dass die kinder eben auch einen
schweren verlauf nehmen ich würde gerne
in der frage noch mal einen schritt
weiter gehen haben könnte man sogar
sagen wenn sich mehr oder die mehrheit
der erwachsenen impfen lassen würde das
die kinder dann vielleicht gar keine
impfungen bräuchten
davon kann man ausgehen wir wissen dass
jahr ausländer mit sehr hoher impfquote
dass es dort gelingt den schutz der
bevölkerung der der gefährdeten
bevölkerung insbesondere so gut zu
gestalten dass die wenigen die sich im
nicht gefährdeten bereich noch anstecken
letztlich auch keine keinen schweren
verlauf haben und dadurch die gesamte
bevölkerung relativ gut geschützt ist
also das ist natürlich ganz klar wenn
wir uns alle impfen als erwachsene wenn
wir es uns gelingt jetzt uns auch
rechtzeitig zu ostern zu lassen durch
die auffrischimpfung dann gelingt es uns
das virus so weit einzudämmen dass wir
das was wir an verantwortung haben
nämlich unsere kinder zu schützen auch
erreichen und wir können den kindern
vielleicht an der einen oder anderen
stelle nicht nur ersparen dass sie
schule verpassen dass die soziales leben
verpassen sondern vor allem auch
ersparen und das gilt jetzt an die
eltern die eben dann doch bedenken haben
ihre kinder zu impfen dass man sie im
voraus
sie haben es gerade angesprochen andere
länder da wollen wir jetzt auch mal
hinschauen israel impft jetzt fünf bis
elfjährige kanada beginnt jetzt auch
damit und in den usa sind schon
zweieinhalb millionen kinder geimpft
worden und von dort aus berichtet
benjamin daniel
nicht nur in diesem zentrum in los
angeles kalifornien feiern sie jeden
einzelnen picks
in den usa werden täglich zehntausende 5
bis 11 jährige gegen cockpit 19 geimpft
eine davon ist die siebenjährige nora
aus new york ihr vater arbeitet hier in
der klinik er weiß dass schwere verläufe
bei kindern selten sind und doch hat er
einige erlebt
als kinder herzspezialist habe ich
selbst gesehen welche auswirkungen eine
cupid infektion auf das herz von kindern
haben kann wie zerstörerisch das virus
wirkt und wie kinder daran steigen
deshalb bin ich sehr froh dass meine
tochter nun viel besser geschützt ist
rund zehn prozent der kinder zwischen
fünf und elf jahren sind mittlerweile
mit mindestens einer dosis geimpft
verabreicht werden zwei drittel der
menge die menschen erhalten die zwölf
jahre und älter sind
die nebenwirkungen sind bisher mild
begrenzt und vergleichbar mit jenen die
wir auch bei erwachsenen arbeiten die am
häufigsten auftretende nebenwirkungen
ist ein schmerzender an
das sind viele kinder bereit auszuhalten
besonders wenn superman persönlich
vorbeikommt um die impfung zu geben neue
nebenwirkungen die nicht aus den studien
bekannt waren sind seit der zulassung
des impfstoffs für fünf bis elfjährige
ende oktober bisher nicht gemeldet
worden
beitrag den arzt gesehen der eben von
schweren verläufen berichtet welche
erfahrungen haben sie dabei sich in der
klinik gesammelt
es ist so dass spezialisten natürlich
für bestimmte erkrankungen und das war
ein herzspezialist für kinder natürlich
auch eine häufung von schweren verläufen
sehen denn dort kommen dann die schweren
verläufe zusammen zum glück haben wir in
unserer klinik keine oder sehr selten
nur sehr schwere verläufe gesehen wir
hatten einige kinder in der phase der
ersten und der zweiten welle auf unseren
intensivstationen auch einige kinder mit
der zweiten erkrankungswelle also diesem
pimps syndrom und diese konnten aber
glücklicherweise die intensivstationen
alle auch wieder verlassen aber es ist
kein angenehmes gefühl für ein kind und
auch für die eltern nicht in sorge zu
sein wenn das kind schwer krank ist und
in die klinik kommt und insofern ist es
wichtig sich damit auseinanderzusetzen
ob die kinder durch eine impfung nicht
profitieren können und ein solcher
seltener schwerer verlauf aber dann doch
gravierender verlauf vermieden werden
kann
war mir eben die instanzen gezeigt bei
kinder und jugendlichen
erwarten sie jetzt auch um oder bereiten
sie sich bei auf ihrer station vor augen
dass das mehr fälle jetzt auch in den
kommenden wochen angewiesen werden
also glücklicherweise hatten wir sehr
sehr wenige kinder trotz der hohen
inzidenz zahlen seit den sommerferien
auf unseren stationen wir sind im moment
viel stärker durch das so genannte rs
virus ist ein erkältungsvirus
belegt da sind 20 oder mehr kinder oft
in den kliniken wir haben in den letzten
wochen ein einziges kind mit cupid bei
uns gehabt also befürchten dass nicht
andererseits muss man auch folgende
szenen bei den sehr hohen inzidenz
zahlen die bei kindern berichtet werden
liegt auch vieles daran dass die kinder
sehr sehr gut getestet werden sie werden
in den schulen gut getestet und wir
haben da ein so gut etabliert das
testsystem dass es beispielsweise auch
gelingt die vermehrten ansteckungen die
hauptsächlich in den ferien stattfinden
und im familiären umfeld und gar nicht
so sehr in der schule diese vermehrten
ansteckungen durch gute tests und durch
eine gutes management eben nach diesen
tests herunterzufahren und das haben wir
beispielsweise im bundesland nordrhein
westfalen sehr schön gesehen nach den
sommerferien wie wir ein sehr hohes
niveau von instanzen durch den
schulbesuch durch testungen wieder auf
ein niedriges niveau bringen konnten
deswegen die schulen sind ein faktor der
er schützt vor infektionen und deswegen
ist es auch so wichtig sie hier in
dieser situation offen zu halten und bis
zum letzten moment auch im regelbetrieb
zu ermöglichen also sie meinen in dem
sinne die schulen sind ein sicherer ort
durch die regelmäßigen testungen denn am
luftbilder anlagen und so ein gramm es
gibt sehr viele orts immer noch nicht
muss man leider sagen
er hat noch eine frage oder bzw ein
statement er er schreibt auf youtube
wenn der impfstoff so toll und harmlos
ist wie stets verkündet warum besteht
dann auch bei der verabreichung an
kindern ein haftungsausschluss für die
impfstoff hersteller können sie das
vielleicht erläutern
ja also wir
untersuchen ja jetzt auch noch die
wirksamkeit und auch die nebenwirkungen
des impfstoffes das ist ganz wichtig das
ist eben so dass ja einen eine notfall
zulassung ausgesprochen wird für den
impfstoff weil wir uns eben in einem
besonderen lage befinden und bei einer
solchen notfall zulassung ist eben vom
gesetzgeber her vorgesehen dass man die
hersteller eines impfstoffes eben von
der haftung entbindet wenn eine reguläre
zulassung erfolgt das ist eben bei den
meisten medikamenten ein prozess der
über mehrere jahre geht dann hat man
natürlich eine andere situation da wird
also keinen haftungsausschluss
ausgesprochen dass der
haftungsausschluss ist nicht so sehr
eine begründung eine inhaltliche
begründung in zu erwartenden
nebenwirkungen des impfstoffes sondern
er hat seine begründung in dem prozess
der impfstoff zulassung der hier ein
anderer ist weil eben die pandemie auch
eine schnellere reaktion erfordert also
sie sehen vielleicht an den fragen der
wird noch ganz viel aufklärungsarbeit zu
leisten sein und informationsarbeit weil
die verunsicherung und teilweise
möglicherweise auch das misstrauen doch
groß ist noch eine frage zum judith ist
die stellt andreas auf youtube also
myokarditis bayon tag eins zu
fünftausend scheint die häufigkeit einer
herzmuskelentzündung zu sein und ihm
erscheint diese zahl erschreckend hoch
ob man da nicht lieber auf andere
impfstoffe warten sollte
es wurde in der
empfehlungs situation bei den 12 bis 17
jährigen verglichen wie hoch die
herzmuskelentzündung sind durch die
kogit infektion und wie hoch sie sind
eben durch die impfung und das hat der
kardiologe aus israel ja eben auch
erwähnt dass das doch relativ häufig
auch zu einer herzmuskelentzündung durch
die infektion selbst kommt und nach
aktuell vorliegenden studien liegt sie
etwa sechsmal höher bei der infektion
als sie bei der impfung liegt also
insofern ist es völlig richtig das ist
eine relativ hohe zahl von
herzmuskelentzündungen bei kindern und
jugendlichen die man sieht und deswegen
wird auch die vorsicht walten gelassen
dass wir jetzt eben das jetzt eben nicht
sofort eine empfehlung für die impfung
aller kinder ausgesprochen wird sondern
dass man eben erst einmal wartet was
ergeben die daten was ergeben die
seltenen die analysen der seltene
nebenwirkung und erst dann wird man sich
durch die stiko zu einer allgemeinen
empfehlung für oder gegen eine impfung
aller kinder aussprechen
es gibt expertinnen die warnen vor allem
vor den spätfolgen wie zum beispiel
longo wird und plädieren daher für die
impfung wir wollen mal kurz rein hören
was die virologin jana schröder dazu
sagt
wissenschaftlichen erkenntnisse gibt
dass es keine spätfolgen für kinder gibt
sind kinder auch zu schützen es wäre
tragisch wenn du in ein paar jahren
feststellen können das ist falsch war
kindern ungefähr 1 zu schließen
wie würden sie das thema bewerten gerade
stichwort lankowitz
longo wird ist in der tat noch ein
unsicherheitsfaktor wir haben keine gute
studienlage weil law mit
das liegt an verschiedenen
schwierigkeiten die wir bei der erhebung
der daten haben zum einen daran dass wir
das long beach syndrom noch nicht sehr
gut definieren können erinnert und
ähnelt vielen anderen erkrankungen wie
zum beispiel depressionen die ja auch
folge der pandemie sein können auf der
anderen seite ist es auch relativ schwer
menschen zu befragen die kurve hatten
und wissen das sie vielleicht später
folgen haben denn diese menschen haben
die erwartung dass sie möglicherweise
später auch probleme haben und dadurch
ist auch das studienergebnis mitunter
verfälscht das erklärt warum die
datenlage noch so unklar ist und so
unsicher im hinblick auf longo witt das
einzige was man mit hoher
wahrscheinlichkeit sagen kann je kleiner
die kinder desto unwahrscheinlicher
slongo witt je stärker sie sich dem
erwachsenenalter annähern desto höher
ist dann auch die wahrscheinlichkeit
dass sie ähnlich wie ein erwachsener
longo witt erleben können es geht gerade
sehen was relativ häufig angesprochen
wird bei uns im kanal ist das des films
syndrom bei in der altersklasse der
fünf- bis zwölfjährigen vielleicht
können sie dazu noch mal was sagen und
uns ein paar erläuterungen geben
ja dass kims zentrum entsteht dadurch
dass der körper auf das virus antwortet
mit einer starken immunreaktion denn das
immunsystem versucht natürlich das virus
zu zerstören manchmal ist diese
immunreaktion so stark dass sie
überschießend ist dass sie also nicht
nur das virus zerstört sondern
körpereigene strukturen mit angreift das
passiert dann einige wochen später
nachdem die infektion schon abgeklungen
ist dass sich verschiedene organe melden
können und dass es zu fieber kommt organ
beteiligung und einem während
krankheitsgefühl auch es ist also wenn
sie so wollen eine überschießende
immunreaktion oder eine kurze autoimmun
erkrankung die durch co wird ausgelöst
werden kann zum glück haben wir
mittlerweile da sehr gute medikamente
wir können die kinder innerhalb weniger
tage mit medikamenten wie kortison oder
immunglobulinen in der klinik behandeln
und sie verlassen dann doch auch nach
wenigen tagen die klinik wieder gesund
rom möchte noch auf youtube dazu wissen
wie oft das denn ungefähr in dieser
altersklasse vorkommt
wir haben knapp 500 kinder und
jugendliche erfasst in deutschland in
einem register das durch die deutsche
gesellschaft für kinder- infektiologie
betrieben wird man muss natürlich sagen
wir wissen nicht aber alle fälle dorthin
gemeldet werden aber von der
größenordnung kann man sagen dass sich
also um einen bereich in den hunderten
handelt und das ist natürlich bei der
großen anzahl von kindern die wir in
deutschland haben zum glück keine sehr
häufige komplikation ich würde gerne
nochmal dieses thema off label impfungen
ansprechen also dass ärztinnen und ärzte
schon eben vor der offiziellen zulassung
für diese altersgruppe in deutschland
die kinder impfen da gibt es ja sogar
jetzt mittlerweile eine initiative im
netz wo eltern impftermine vermitteln
für kinder und dazu gibt es auch eine
frage auf youtube wie denn die
expertinnen und experten zu off label
impfung für kinder unter fünf jahren
stehen dann möchte jemand wissen und
schreibt meine kinder sind unter 5
besser warten auf die ehemals zulassung
mehr gut die haben wir jetzt was
wahrscheinlich die
stiko empfehlungen gemeint und das haben
wir natürlich auch martin terhardt
gefragt da können wir noch mal rein
ich kann viele eltern deren kinder
wirkliche sorgenkinder sind weil sie ein
starkes risiko haben verstehen die jetzt
schon so schnell wie möglich an diese
impfung bekommen kommen möchten oder die
das auch schon gemacht haben auf dem weg
den die skizziert haben aber das ist
eine grauzone ist juristisch nicht ganz
klar es ist eine off label impfung bis 1
benutzt er dafür nicht zugelassen ist es
muss eine sehr viel geringere menge
aufgezogen werden mit der spritze und
gegeben werden wo durchaus dosierung
fehler möglich sind wo man auch nicht
ganz hundertprozentig immer sicher sagen
kann ob dadurch ganz schutz erzeugt wird
man darf diesen impfstoff nicht weiter
verdünnen um eine größere menge in die
spritze zu bekommen und deswegen ist der
kinder impfstoff ja auch völlig anders
zubereitet worden kommt in einer völlig
anderen flasche auf den markt mit
anderen lösungsmittel mit anderen puffer
um den zu stabilisieren und es wird eine
menge von 0.2 milliliter dann für die
kinder unter zwölf jahren gegeben und
deswegen wir müssen leider auf diesen
neuen zubereiteten impfstoff warten der
weg jetzt den erwachsenen impfstoff in
niedrigere dosierung einfach für die
kinder zu benutzen ist ein weg den ich
nicht empfehlen kann den auch die
zulassungsbehörden in keiner weise
empfehlen
hätte bekommen sie das aus ihrem
medizinischen umfeld mit dass eltern
nach off label impfungen mittlerweile
auf fünf fragen
ja das findet schon seit einiger zeit
statt also die insbesondere die eltern
jetzt der fünf- bis elfjährigen haben in
den letzten wochen und monaten sehr
stark nachgefragt wir haben genau die
empfehlungen abgegeben die der experte
jetzt auch im beitrag
gezeigt hat das wäre doch empfehlen zu
warten
insbesondere vor dem hintergrund dass
die allermeisten kinder ja doch ein
relativ milden verlauf der infektion
durch machen erscheint es uns nicht
sicher und nicht gut 1 nicht zugelassen
und nicht empfohlen den impfstoff zu
geben und das gleiche gilt natürlich
dann jetzt ab jetzt wenn der impfstoff
zugelassen ist und wenn er dann
vielleicht auch irgendwann empfohlen ist
auch für die unter- fünfjährigen auch da
würden werden nicht empfehlen zu impfen
oder impfen zu lassen solange es noch
keine zulassung durch die emea für die
unter- fünfjährigen gibt und so lange es
dann noch keine stiko empfehlung gibt
ich glaube das ist genau das
spannungsfeld das besteht auf der einen
seite die gruppe derer denen das gar
nicht schnell genug gehen kann denen wir
sagen bitte wartet damit sicherheit für
eure kinder besteht und auf der anderen
seite die gruppe derer die sagen egal
wie viel an daten kommt egal wie viel
die was die experten sagen egal wie
sicher wir sind dass es keine
nebenwirkungen gibt wir werden unsere
kinder nicht impfen denn wir vertrauen
nicht und ich glaube da kann nur der
richtige mittelweg sein zu sagen dafür
haben wir eine expertenkommission dafür
haben wir menschen die sich seit
jahrzehnten mit dem thema
auseinandersetzen so viele andere
impfstoffe überprüft haben und diese
menschen urteilen nicht auf basis von
politischen entscheidungen sondern
wirklich auf basis von
klinischen von medizinischen von
wissenschaftlichen fakten und sie sind
nur ihrem eigenen gewissen und ihre
eigenen rechenschafts fähigkeit
unterworfen
ich habe noch eine letzte frage an sie
bzw gar nicht ich sondern maria zibell
auf facebook sie fragt würden sie mit
ihrem wissen als arzt ihre kinder impfen
er ist eine sehr persönliche frage und
ich kann ja so sagen mein sohn sitzt
hier in der nähe und der liegt mit dem
kopf dass ich das sagen darf er wollte
das war 13 jahre alt zu dem zeitpunkt
als es eine zulassung gab und eine stiko
empfehlung für die zwölf- bis
17-jährigen und er hat gesagt ich möchte
geimpft werden auch weil ich in meiner
klasse schülerinnen und schüler habe die
selbst gefährdet sind einen schwereren
verlauf zu haben gehen damit diabetes
kennen da die übergewichtig sind und
deswegen möchte ich einen beitrag
leisten diese kinder zu schützen und ich
fand das eine sehr mutige entscheidungen
ganz tolle entscheidung meines sohnes
und wir sind das sofort mit gegangen
professor dirk ich danke ihnen für das
gespräch und vor allem hoffe ich dass
wir heute abend vielen müttern und
vätern auf dem weg zu ihrer entscheidung
irgendwie weiterhelfen konnten
dankeschön einen schönen abend noch
dankeschön und allen auch einen schönen
abend und alles gute und
natürlich auch ihnen vielen dank und
schönen abend und bis bald